hi I'm Nick Gillespie I'm with my
colleague Matt Welch for the co-authors
of the Declaration of Independence a new
book about how libertarian politics can
fix what's wrong with America we work at
reason check us out of reason.com recent
TV and all over the interwebs our latest
question in ask a libertarian day comes
from sake 75 also known as brian w with
sake and he's got a bone to pick with me
he asked who wrote the majority of the
book PS i bet Nick just put his name on
it like been afflicted with Good Will
Hunting mom I told you not to write in
emails it's just not very nice after all
the health and nick has given you over
the years I know we each wrote a
plurality of the book I think it's fair
to say and the balance was written by
the aqua buddha yeah I think sure and
trivia question and answer for you
playing at home which one of the two of
us appeared literally in a Ben Affleck
look-alike contest on national
television yeah I'm betting it's matt
rather than talking about who wrote the
majority of the book i'd like to point
out who wrote the good parts is really
the question that should be asked and
I'm afraid that's something that the
each reader will have to decide for him
or her or itself mostly it's
you